bad systems can't go on forever
political orders always change
conservatives used to not like that last
part of it because we used to want to
believe hey look the America of
1958 that has to go on forever mid-1950s
America that is the Eternal political
order it has to go on forever and any
deviation from that whatsoever is awful
and terrible in a violation of
everything we hold here and we used to
lament when the left would tell us well
that's not how politics Works things
change all the time we say no we don't
want it to change we want it to remain
exactly the same well yeah it's it's
very sad to know that political orders
always have to change when things are
good but when things are bad and
decadent and corrupted as they are right
now then it's a great consolation and
hope to know that political orders none
of them not the best one not the worst
one none of them go on forever